okay uh you mentioned New York Times
bestseller list you chose to
self-publish yes so we just Linger on
that decision what's what are the pros
and cons of self-publishing the cons are
it is acceptable in our current business
climate or cultural climate for
corporate media Outlets to pretend the
book doesn't exist Yeah so basically and
there's reason for it I can make the
case to them pretty easily
if someone's doing it themselves who is
this guy's some crackpot writing crazy
stuff from his basement right it's a
little different I think for me because
I'm an established author uh C-SPAN gave
me an hour on book TV I'm still a
crackpot but yeah established for dear
reader I think I was the first one to
get an hour on booktv for a book that I
did myself
um so there is space for that
um it didn't go through a vetting
process the way a book going through a
corporate publisher did so those are the
minuses
the pros are
uh I can drop it and publish it
immediately
uh if you go through a corporate
publisher you have to wait a year
um you can do what you could have the
book you want instead of the getting
past the editor and some editors are
very very good and there's a whole
Spectrum some of them not so good some
are good
I know the real killers all right let's
be there's good people on both sides
yeah there's plenty of people at both
sides yeah and I don't mean the white
nationalists who I condemn totally
um
so but the thing is in terms of money
you get six times as much
uh profit when you're self-published
then when you go through corporate
publisher
um the buck stops here it's you know in
one of my books that I co-authored I
won't even mention the name there is a
typo and they didn't they don't care
they didn't fix it for the paperback
edition here since I'm going through
Amazon if there's a typo I can fix it
live and it updates oh yeah yep you can
just update it yeah so that's very
useful like a Fight Club thing where you
can insert like a dick pic in one of the
pages okay why are you so why do you
keep texting me to send you dick pics
talk about your suggestion you're all
right all right all right get I guess
I'm not the editor I get it North Pole I
get it yeah um the other advantage just
socially is I think people are like I
found this with the kickstarter I did
for your reader people are much more
excited to buy it and promote it and
talk about it when they know you're
doing it yourself instead of you're
getting a big check from
you know St Martin's Harper Collins
penguin whatever are you also trying to
use some kind of service to get it
distributed to bookstores or you just go
to do Amazon no just Amazon yeah and
that's probably what most sales happen
the vast majority yeah so it's not going
to be in bookstores so what's how
difficult is the process of getting it
on Amazon so I'll tell you a funny story
about how Amazon works and because this
was a I always plan for because everyone
uh
people's here's another piece of advice
I will give people your life will be a
lot easier if you realize that the
majority of people in every industry are
bad at their jobs like once you have
that realization everything else makes
sense and you your life will be a lot
easier right so when I did the anarchist
handbook which was a collection of
essays from various anarchists
throughout history
when I submitted it to Amazon there was
a lot of copyright issues because
they're like do you have the rights to
this essay do you have the right to this
says they have to go back and forth with
them a lot uh to make sure I had
copyright where everything was public
domain and that and the thing is you
forward you know you update it you get
the information three days there's
another problem it's not three days so
it's weeks the other thing with their
CreateSpace program is the paperback and
the ebook the Kindle are approved
independently so just because it's
approved for one it's not for the other
after I published Amber kiss handbook
and it was a big success
they Unleashed enrolled excuse me a
hardcover Edition uh program so I'm like
oh great I'll put in hardcover they're
like sorry this is too similar to uh
Murray rothbard's Anatomy estate and
which is a pamphlet or short book that
Mary rothbard wrote I go well wait I
have the entirety of anatomy state in
here I have permission from The mises
Institute in writing which I'm giving to
you to reprint it and you guys already
have it been published for a year as a
paperback and ebook and they're like too
bad blocked so it's not available as a
hardcover on Amazon even though it's
available maybe now it's going to be
pulled as paperback an ebook so with
this book I was anticipating all right
there's going to be some whatever I the
thing with how it works is you have to
upload it and hit publish and then you
got to wait for the approval yeah I'm
like okay this is gonna be who knows I
just wanted to get as fast as possible 4
AM
less than 24 hours I get a notification
congratulations your books available for
sale and have to run downstairs and pull
it yeah from publication because
otherwise it was out and I didn't finish
editing it yeah so that's the situation
there oh that's fascinating but that's
like powerful that's like you're it's
it's all in your hands it's all on you
yes and I think the program is great
um it charts just like any other book
um the quality of the books is great I
am uh very happy with uh I have no I
have no contact with them uh my buddy
Tucker Max he had a company that did
this and they basically helped people
self-publish their own book they did the
Goggins book I think you've talked to
him haven't you uh or yeah maybe they
emailed me or something yeah yeah and he
said I have done dozens maybe hundreds
of books with them I have never been
able to get someone on the phone so I
don't know what's going on over there
but guys if you want to reach out to me
um please call me it's Michael Lex
friedman.com laughs
Friedman is spelled wrong yeah if you
ever have any complaints
please just at me at Twitter
about Michael no
uh why do you why do you think so if you
establish authors
self-publish
I mean why it seems like it makes
perfect sense in this modern society to
be able to when you finish the book to
publish it within a few days a few weeks
I think I talked to Jordan Peterson
about this at length and Michaela his
daughter who I'm also good friends with
she's actually named after Gorbachev
who's the big hero of this book also
friend Michael you know I was in talks
to interview Gorbachev and then covet
hit and that's one of the big regrets of
my life that I didn't get I think if I
met him I would be
on my knees literally kissing his feet
crying uh because of you I mean one of
the big points of the white pill is
there were so many moments
when they were calling him up sending
the tanks we want another Tiananmen
Square and he's like [ __ ] you so when
you have anyone who has the capacity to
murder
thousands of people and chooses to
withhold that power like all I could do
is applaud he resisted the cynicism yes
wait so the why the authors why I don't
publish all the books I think they're
still in the you know how like there's
this whole idea about how if you're a
movie actor you don't go on TV because
that kind of ruins your brand so and
that's kind of going away there's a lot
of shows where the lead is now like a
former movie actor and this is kind of
like they're a big thing like Matthew
McConaughey you know he had a TV show um
on HBO I believe so I think there's this
kind of like wait a minute what's that
and he reset I said all right
you see all right all right all right
all right
Matthew McConaughey all right all right
I don't I don't I don't know what that
is sorry
um just I'll explain it this is what
look at the context below okay so I
think for them it might be a a loss of
credibility to some extent but B they
their agent
whose job is to sell them and get a big
Advance wouldn't be encouraged to
self-publish because you know so I don't
think it's percolated to powerful people
yet how feasible this is and how
profitable it is and how they'll still
be able to reach Their audience
um and I feel if you know I don't if
Anarchist handbook wasn't such a
gigantic success
um I would be much more nervous about
the white pill but the fact that it was
and that I saw it from start to finish
and I know the ins and outs now I'm like
what are you guys bringing to the table
so that's taking a year of my time and
introducing edits that I would not
otherwise agree with I think for some
people a book is a
is the sort of Beacon of reputation so
like so it's really important to not
there's somehow not as much reputation
associated with a self-published book
unless it's successful yes and then and
then like the it's success outshines the
actual however it was published I think
I guess David Goggins self-published uh
his book because it used to be you
self-publish when you can't get a book
deal so it's like an admission of
failure
yeah so you would recommend it as
something for for authors no I would
recommend it as something for authors of
a certain stature for lack a better term
because it is still in terms of your
resume and your experience it's better
to get a crappy advance and have a book
with Saint Martins that goes nowhere
than a self-published book that goes
nowhere so the other thing is you have
to make sure you have enough an audience
that you can move some copies
what about only fans would you recommend
authors
how much money do you think you and I
can make if we didn't like bathtub
scenes in only fans not just chilling
just reading like reading like Animal
Farm just like while sitting in reality
I don't know okay snowflake
okay
uh uh all right what was his name no the
horse uh boxer I'm hung like a boxer
I I will work harder
and that guy I think about that guy a
lot boxer yeah he's uh his model was I
will work harder anything that happens
like the the the pigs would take
advantage and his response to everything
he was inspiring to me because he never
gave in to the cynicism right and they
killed him yeah spoiler sorry
but that's a good way to die never
giving in
well yeah there's a lot of that in this
book about the people who are like I'm
not you're not gonna break me like I'm
bigger than this